mối tình yêu đi chị cưng ơi
thật á tháng nay có điều hot thế cơ á
chứ còn gì nữa
đây là bí kíp của chị em
chúng tôi rút Ra được sau mỗi phiên live
trùm điêu lên live của shop iPhone
thấy mọi người chưa biết cái môi nhiều
nên là chị em
tụi tui làm video này để hướng dẫn mọi người nha
đảm bảo là không có AI hướng dẫn kỹ
như chị em tụi tui đâu nên là nhớ xem hết đó nha
ô kê đầu tiên thì phải làm gì hả chị
đầu tiên là mình phải vào live đó cưng
đúng rồi thế nên là mình không thể bỏ lỡ
phiên live hàng tháng của Shopee
mỗi tháng chỉ có một lần và vào tháng tư này thì
phiên live sẽ diễn Ra vào ngày 19
thôi đó mọi người ơi
AI mà chưa rõ thông tin
thì có thể Theo dõi thêm thông tin ở trên fanpage
Shopee Food nha
nói nhỏ Theo kinh nghiệm thì
thường sẽ diễn Ra vào tuần thứ BA của mỗi tháng
giờ mọi người Theo dõi kỹ để biết cách mua nha
bước một nhấn vào biểu tượng giỏ hàng và
tìm sản phẩm mình muốn mua tại giỏ hàng nhá
nhưng mà lưu ý là mọi người phải chọn đúng sản phẩm ở
thành phố mà mình đang sống
và check khoảng cách từ quán đến địa điểm nhận món nhá
bước 2 chọn
điều yêu thích
nhớ đọc kỹ tên điêu và nhấn mua ngay tại livestream
bước BA mua xong thì phải thanh toán chứ còn gì nữa
nhưng mà nhớ lưu ý là phải
thanh toán không bằng tiền mặt nhá
điều mọi người hay nhầm lẫn là mua xong tới shipper
giao luôn Sai
nhưng thực Ra
trùm điêu là in voucher có thể hạn sử dụng trong 7 ngày
nên là mọi người cần bấm sử dụng như sau
bước một xem đơn đã mua trong mục chờ giao hàng
bước 2 nhấn sử dụng bước BA
nhập voucher free ship có sẵn trong ví và bấm tạm biệt ôi
combo KFC 4 G dán kèm nước 200 k 2 k chỉ còn 116.000 thôi
chào bạn Katinat 54 k chỉ còn 22 k
Katinat có vốn mới matcha bắp 60 k mà còn có 29 k
thôi
ăn như mình chứ hông bao giờ ăn trên live vậy đó
giao 2 cái này nó vẫn còn giòn